Here's what I like to do. You pointed out some issues that you
were concerned about and I thought that maybe you could go and look into
it a bit more and you did. And so why don't I turn
things over to you so that you can tell us what you've found out.
>> Okay, well thank you Michael. Hi again.
>> Hi.
>> Thank you Michael. So I did go and I started
trying to deal with these issues. So just to recap a
little bit, there were two problems that I had, more or
less. And they were, that we had all these cool little randomized
optimization algorithms. And, most of them seemed to share this property
that the only thing that really happened over time, is you started
out with some point and you ended up with some point,
which was supposed to be, you know, the optimal point. And the
only difference between the first point, and the last point that
you did or, the one millionth point or however how many you
iterations you had, is that, that point might have been closer
to the optimum by some measure. And very little structure was actually
being kept around or communicated. Only the point was being
communicated. Now you could argue that that isn't quite true with
genetic algorithms, but really you move from a single point
to just a few points. The other problem that I had
is that we had all of this sort of probability
theory that was underneath what we were doing, all this randomization.
But somehow it wasn't at all clear in most of
the cases, exactly what probability distribution we were dealing with. Now,
one thing I really liked about some [UNKNOWN]
is that you were very clear about what
the probability distribution was. So what I decided to do is to go out there in
the world and see if I could find maybe a class of algorithms that took care
of these two points for us. And I
found something, you'll be very happy hear, Michael.
>> Yeah, I would love to, to find out what it is.
>> It turns out that I wrote a paper about this, almost 20 years ago.
>> [LAUGH] How did you find that?
>> I just
said, well if I wanted to start looking someplace,
I should look at home first. And I stumbled across
>> Oh.
>> this paper that I wrote.
>> I see, I see. So learning about machine learning, really begins at home.
>> That's exactly right. So, I had to
re-read the paper because, you know, it is
a coupl of decades old. And I will point that a lot of other work has been
done since this that refines on these ideas.
But, this is fairly straightforward and simple, so,
I think I am just going to stick with
this work. And the paper's available for everyone listening
this to right now or watching this right now. So you can read it and
all of it's gory details. But I just want to go over the, the high level bit
here because I, I, I really think it
kind of gets at this idea. So, in particular,
the paper that I'm talking about introduced an
algorithm called Mimic, which actually stands for something,
though I forget what. And it really had a very simple structure
to it. The basic idea was to directly model a probability distribution.
>> Probability distribution of what?
>> Well, I'll tell you. And, you know, like I said,
Michael, I will, define exactly what this, probability distribution is for you
for a second and, and hopefully you'll, you'll buy that it seems
like a reasonable distribution to model. And given that you have this,
probability distribution that you're directly modeling, the, the goal
is to do this sort of search through space, just
like we did with all the rest of these
algorithms. And to successfully refine the estimate of that distribution.
>> Hm.
>> And the idea is that if you can directly model this
distribution and refine it over time that, that will in fact convey structure.
>> Structure in particular of what were learning
about the search space while we're doing the search.
>> Exactly, and not just simply the structure of the
search space, but the structure of the parts of the
space that represent good points or points that are more
optimal than others. Yeah, that seems like a really useful thing.
>> So I'm just going to give you, again, this, this simple mimic algorithm
that, that sort of captures these basic
ideas, because I think it's fairly simple
and easy to understand, while still getting
some of the underlying issues. But do
keep in mind that there's been literally
decades of work since then, and optimization
space where people have really taken these kinds of ideas and
refined them to be sort of much more mathematically precise. But this,
I think, does get the idea across, and I happen to
understand it, so I thought that I would share it with you.
>> Hm.
>> Seem fair?
>> Yeah, that sounds really exciting.
>> Excellent.